hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Saturday as we will be
interrupting our capablanca saga but
only briefly to show you this very nice
game it's played in the in round three
of the Iberia international tournament
in San Francisco and we have a young
feeding master from the United States
Christopher you who is only 12 years old
playing against well renowned Vietnamese
a grandmaster laQuan Liam and look what
Liam is somewhere around 27 15 I believe
in classical rating and Christopher you
is 2388 so there is a quite quite a bit
of a difference in in ratings and it's
really really an interesting game so I
do hope you enjoy it and it's
interesting like I said the U is 12
years old Huang Liam is 27 years old so
it's a similar age difference like in
our cup of Uncas October 13 year old Cup
along he's playing against a 27 year old
one Corzo but I do hope you enjoy it so
let's check out this very nice game we
have E for by young Christopher and c6
the caro-kann defense d4 d5 and here
Christopher goes for eke after Sun d5 so
the exchange variation of the coral Khan
meaning that he wants to avoid a lot of
lines that black can go if he doesn't go
for the exchange variation but also that
he decides which variation will be
played and he definitely prepared
something seek a course on d5 Knight to
f3
we have Knight to c6 and now Bishop to
b5 pinning the night we have e 6 and
here there are a couple of moves that
are known in this position
castles was played here in 95 is a known
move attacking the pin piece and c3 is a
known move but here c4 is a move that
has never been played before it already
on move six and it means Christopher
really came prepared for this game and
okay we have a completely new game now D
captures on c4 and Christopher castles
black keeps on developing Bishop to b6
white will capture back the pawn at some
point so there is no rush
we have nice to see three and now 97 now
that the Knight has been placed on e7 at
the light the darks burger shop is
developed Bishop to g5 pinning the night
we have castles by laQuan Liam and now
Bishop captures on c4 as the Bishop is
no longer pinning the King and here b6
we have a three bishop to b7 and here
rook to e1 and if you look at this
position black now has excellent
development both of the blacks bishops
are excellent eyeing that white king and
g1 the knight is nicely developed the
rook is coming to c8 the queen will at
some point move and the rook will also
come into the game so the only thing
black needs to figure out how to how to
get rid of this pin and black decides
the first go rook to see it as the
bishop on c4 is undefended so some nice
discoveries would be possible a
Christopher moves the bishop bishop to
a2 and now comes h6 Liam forces
Christopher to they decide what he's
going to do with the bishop or whether
he wants to capture of course you don't
want to do this why give up the bishop
repair so brush up to 84 and now Queen
to d7 breaking the pin and also making
room for this rook to enter the game
we have d5 now a very nice move that
allows for some exchanges in the center
eeeek after Sun d5 Knight captures on d5
Knight captures on d5 and rush of
chapters on d5 we have rook f38 now
opposing this rook on an open file
rook captures on e8 we look after Sonny
eight and now King to h1 a nice
prophylactic move know if the Queen ever
moves
no Bishop captures and an HT to check
ideas will be possible with picking off
the bishop but also we don't want to
allow such things anyway we have g5 and
this is the one of the critical moments
of the game where laQuan liam is hoping
for this variation he attacks the bishop
is hoping for Bishop to g3
Bishop captures pawn captures and now
rook to d8 attacking the bishop here the
only way to defend the bishop is to move
it to b3 to also guard the Queen and
here our black would have a lot of
options he could go Queen to a5 to keep
the Queen's on the board or he could
simply just exchange everything ro
captures rook captures Bishop captures
and here after a five black would have a
better position yes the material is
equal black White's pawn structure is
some
my stop on the kingside but black hood
black can never lose this and well as
long liam is a much higher rated player
a much stronger player he would he would
enjoy playing this game and you know he
he could play it for as long as he wants
to until he maybe create some winning
chances but his young adversary after g5
does not allow this variation after
Bishop to g3 rather he decides to
sacrifice a piece Bishop captures on g5
and okay it's a piece for two pawns H
captures and Knight captures and ok
already are threatening the capture on
f7 and here Knight the d8 was played
offering a trade of light squared bishop
and also the night from D it protects
the f7 point a much better defense was
king to g7 but this is something that
will we'll be seeing a lot in this game
how even such a strong player like la
Kwang lien it has trouble defending and
it's a saying in chess it's always
easier to attack them to defend here if
you just played King g7 then there is a
really no problem white can capture this
pawn let's say Bishop captures now you
get rook to a trade already black is
starting the attack you keep your bishop
pair to attack the white king after h3
in queen is coming to e7 and all is well
everything in black blacks camp is
defended the black simply continues
playing this game ideas like 25 become
possible and it will be it will be a
very promising position for black but ok
after 95 with 98 going after the f7 pawn
defending the f7 pawn and now Bishop
captures you cannot capture with the
Queen because the bishop is hanging on
d6 so you would have to play Knight
captures on b7 we have Queen to d3 now
going for some Queen h7 business and
here again King to FA displayed f5 would
have been a much sturdier defense here
if Queen to d5 chip you will simply move
the king and after H for protecting the
night rookie 7
now the rook is also protecting the
night here the Queen can now move the
queen is coming T 8 this rock is coming
to e1 a much more more solid approach to
defending in this position but here lien
goes for King to f8 and now comes Queen
to d4 again
with some possibilities of queen h8 and
maybe night h7 followed by Queen to f6
again a lot of possibilities here and
here if you play something like King to
e7 that's perfectly fine you can start
running away with your king now there's
no night h7 check there's no Queen f6 if
you go rook you wanna check the black
King will simply hide King d8 and this
is this is perfectly fine
rook c1 cutting off the C file but Queen
to f5 and now black is still in the game
if after Queen to d4 you don't go King
g7 you could try something like rook to
e2 this is also possible for example if
now knife to h7 check King is 7 now
Queen to f6 comes but now you white will
be able to force a draw here let's say
you you go back in the 8th as hurricane
gate Queen h8 27 in f6 check and here
wife will be able to force a draw with a
perpetual check
but as laQuan liam is much higher rated
and of course he does not want to draw
he continues fighting so he plays rook
to e5 and yeah this bay area
international tournament in san
francisco it's a the the prize money for
for first prize is $5,000 so it's
basically a tournament were renowned
players like Wang Liam come come to grab
some easy money and were young young
fede masters like Christopher you come
to take some international norms in his
case he would very much like to earn his
international master nor but okay rook
to e5 attacking the knight on g5 and now
f4 defending the knight but now we have
Queen to g4 you cannot capture the rook
as the Queen on d4 is undefended sorry
about that
undefended and rook to d1 now the Queen
is defended and capturing the rook is
definitely a possibility here we have
rook to e2 and here laQuan William is
already threatening checkmate on g2 but
this doesn't work so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only
possible line that is playable here for
white I will give you a couple of
seconds as it is a Saturday you know
feel free to use your time wisely for
those of you who
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent player as this is not an easy
line to find but in photos we just want
to enjoy the show
the idea is night to h7 check and now
you see the problem if you go King to e8
or King to g8 then Knight to f6 check
will pick up the Queen on g4 you don't
want to allow this so the only move
available to you is king the e7 this is
what laQuan lien played and now we have
Queen to f6 check which was played in
the game and now you can either go to d7
or to e8 the problem with King to e8 of
course you would very much like the
checkmate here is Queen to HH check and
now after King to e7 Queen to f8 check
King to d7 and now you can see that the
f6 where it's available for the Knights
to deliver this check
neither six check for King the king and
the Queen here on g4 King to c6 and now
your queen is also under attack on f8 so
first you will grab the bishop here
Queen captures Knight captures and now
comes Knight captures and g4 and after
rook after Sun b2 you will simply
continue playing this game and you will
be you will be better here King goes to
C 7h 4 is coming your H bone is marching
up the board now most likely white will
be winning here so you don't have the
option of actually going to e8 so King
to d7 was played which is much better
you might think as the queen is on f6
now there is no night to have 6 check to
pick up the Queen and g4 but Christopher
you had this all figured out the Queen
captures on d6 with check grabbing the
bishop and also moving the Queen from f6
so now Knight to f6 check is coming and
you cannot move the King as the Queen is
guarded by the rook Knight captures and
now comes Knight to f6 check King has to
move now comes Knight captures on g4 and
now comes the rook captures on b2 so
here after all this craziness
Christopher you is simply up a pawn and
it's a very dangerous H bone which is a
passed pawn and as you know those are
the fastest but ok 9 3 3 we have rook to
e2 attacking the knight and now comes
Knight to d5
we have Knight to c4 and here comes h4
already Christopher is not
two marches past one of the board King
to f5
we have h5 and now comes look to e6 the
rook is not preventing the bone from
advancing to the sixth rank and rook to
c1
the knight is under attack Knight goes
back to C to D 6 and now King to G 1
starting to also bring the King into the
game King to g4 going after the h5 pawn
and here we have rook to c7 and again we
have this moment where electrons liam is
playing against a much lower rated
opponent to more than 300 rating points
and here if he just captures the pawn he
eliminates the past pawn rook captures
an a7 is coming and most likely this
endgame would resolve in a in a draw at
some point white is still up a pawn but
surely black will be able to hold this
but we have a 5 even down upon laQuan
Liam wants to keep chances of a win on
the board perhaps if he can create a
passed pawn here he can still play for a
win but ok we have rook the c6 now going
after the b6 pawn b5 and now comes
Knight to the c7 with an attack on this
rook and now you have a problem here
laQuan liam played rook to e7 with the
idea ok if you kept through my knight I
will capture your knight but now the
position is simply dead lost for black
I feel free to pause the video again and
now find the winning move for young
Christopher here for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent and game player and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show the move is h6 you simply start
marching your pawn down the board and
now the idea that laQuan liam head off
playing f5 to control this rank doesn't
work because of knights the d5 and now
you see the problem your knight is under
attack your look is under attack and you
can't even give up the knight to block
the pawn or anything
you can't even protect the night because
of 90 f6 check this Knight to f6 check
controls the d7 square and also the h7
squared that the pawn will use to
advance forward so here there's really
not much to do also if f5 you can't
really there is no move that you can
play here 95 is simply too strong a move
which would be winning so here after 8
six liam tried 92f five attacking the
pawn here and now comes h7 i mean i mean
why not
and how do you prevent upon to h8 the
the knight is covering e8 so there's
only one way to do it rook e1 check King
has to move we are king to f2 and now
comes a rook to h1 defending the pawn
now of course you cannot advance the
point immediately but you still have
nice to d5 check sorry Knights to d5 and
now if rook captures on h7 you simple
play Knight to f6 check again and well
we can show it it again picks up the
rook so it's not possible after Knight
to d5 with ninth to g3 and if you could
only somehow move your king somewhere
but you can't all of the squares are
unavailable the f4 square is guarded by
the knight the black soul Knight is
blocking the King from advancing g5
covered by the pawn and if you put the
King of course on the h-file then white
is free to promote so nice g3 hoping to
now advance the King and Knight to f6
check will not be an issue but look the
c8 now going protecting the the queening
square that is h8 94 check we have King
to e3 and now black has no longer any
options rook captures on h7 must be
played King captures on e4 and now comes
rogue to h6 a white is now up a full
night and with the same amount of pawns
this is of course a winning game nights
the e3 check was played here and it was
in this position that look Wang Liam
resigned in the game so a wonderful
victory for young Christopher you who is
well closer and closer to achieving his
international master roll norm would be
an excellent ordeal for a 12 year old 12
year old player and yeah it's
interesting quite a quick somewhat
different than the had a cup of Blanca
versus one Corso saga that we're
covering as you know there kappa blanka
had no knowledge of the opening theory
at all and here you can see that times
have changed young Christopher already
surprised look on Julian with a
variation that was never played before
and move six but that's that's the
the kind of chess that is being played
today ah
but yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I found this game talk with a
lot of send it to me he's the official
photographer of the tournament and he
sent me a couple of nice photos of
Christopher this one and a few more the
ones I will be using in a thumbnail as
well so feel free to check out that
latticework I will put a few of his
links for his social media in the
description below he's an excellent
photographer so do check him out I would
like to thank Kurt Mulder James Dobson
Demetri Franza yan Roy and Robert
Silverman for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
video serie thank all for watching and I
will see you soon with some more games
from the capablanca saga but also the
Tata Steel is starting soon so we're
gonna be covering that simultaneously as
well thank you all and I'll see you soon
and have an excellent rest of the
Saturday